I'm super pumped about this collab but  what does it mean for you be friends  partners with Kim shui one of the great  up-and-coming female fashion designers  in the world but why do we want to do  this fb friends besides the fact that  she makes the most epic hoodie that I've  ever worn it's because she's crushing in  her universe and that's a universe that  beat brands has not gotten into yet as I  build demand and interest and Intrigue  and be friends doing collaborations and  different things and universes where my  brand or the v-friends brand has not  been yet is interesting but it has to be  authentic I meet with tons of people but  after having drinks with Kim we hit it  off friendships and most of all she was  driven hence why we picked the driven  Dragon to be the collaborator it was  authentic it got into New spaces and a  lot more of you should be doing these  kind of collaborations